[Music]
hollywood superstar tom hanks has been
to eisenhuttenstadt twice
he says he's a fan of former communist
germany's model city
the last time he was here he bought a
trobby an experience in eastern comfort
it all worked eisenhutenstadt is
thriving
25 years after the fall of the wall at
least at first glance
the city center has been fully renovated
the city's biggest
employer is now in private hands some
new factories have even opened up
unemployment hovers around nine percent
a low
number for eastern germany
[Music]
people living in eisenhower are used to
living in an industrial city
people are fine working at all times of
the day we have great kindergartens and
great schools
but it hasn't been easy the city still
relies heavily on steel production
in 1990 an international concern bought
the city's old steel plant
that saved around 5 000 jobs
in 1997 former chancellor helmut cole
declared steel production a national
priority
his government went on to invest 300
million euros into eisenhuttenstadt's
city works
that was really important because it was
a really big project especially this
rolling mill here
it was also necessary to upgrade gaps in
technology in eisenhooten
if we didn't have this rolling mill we
wouldn't be working here today
we just couldn't compete
competition with other cities is a big
topic in spain
the city has just come out of a
difficult period
25 percent of working age people were
once unemployed
that number has now dropped to around 16
or 17 percent
golden bach next is a local ice cream
vendor he was born and raised in schweit
his ice cream shop doesn't attract
enough customers it only gets crowded on
hot days
like today
i'd say about 85 of the young people
have left
my boys left too i don't know what's
going to become of this place
they've done a lot build this pier here
but what's missing are the jobs
schweint was another model industrial
city in communist east germany
its largest employer the petrochemicals
company pck
schweight was a boom town back in the
60s but after reunification the city's
businesses couldn't compete
thousands of jobs were cut young people
left
old people stayed politicians didn't
know how to respond
for decades the city shrank entire
housing blocks stand empty
no one knows what the future holds we're
planning
we're planning now up to 2025 we hope of
course that we can turn things around
eisenhuttenstadt has also struggled with
people leaving the city for better
opportunities elsewhere
fifty thousand people used to live in
eisenhuttenstadt
today it's not even thirty thousand
buildings stand empty along the
outskirts of the city
those who can't find a job in the city
have no choice but to search elsewhere
older residents remain behind who wants
to live in a city that has so little to
offer
when i've been gone for a while and come
back sometimes i count the number of
people who are under 50 or 60.
and there aren't that many
for all its losses eisenhuttenstadt has
been able to attract a number of new
businesses to the city
that's something spain can only dream
about just like before everything
revolves around the old petrochemicals
company pck
still not even pck is secure nor is
friendship
drishpa is the russian word for
friendship and that's the name of the
oil pipeline that runs from siberia
through ukraine to schweit
no wonder people here are closely
following the ukraine conflict
eu sanctions against russia hang like a
sword of damocles over the city
and that's not the only problem
in the we have really big disadvantages
compared to
for example north rhine westphalia
because we don't have any other
industrial clients
spate doesn't have enough industrial
opportunity and
it lacks proper educational facilities a
large sport and cultural center aren't
enough to keep people from leaving the
city
it's dead quiet in the town center young
people have left in droves for bigger
cities in the west
a sculpture on the riverbank mirrors the
city's troubled hopes for the future
the younger generation the girls they
don't want to become
bakers or sales clerks or hairdressers
they want to study
they want to do things like i.t they
want more than this city has to offer
[Music]
two different cities on two different
paths but they share the same problem
german politicians have failed to ensure
a sustainable future for the city's
residents
if the old industrial plans have to
close it will mean the end for both
schweit
and eisenhuttenstadt